we are back at it again with more
spider-man news
yes spider-man is back in the MCU but
now the question is for how long
what's up everyone it's Warren and yes
spider-man is back in the MCU but for
how much longer after much back and
forth Sony and Marvel finally came to an
agreement and spider-man is now in the
MCU for two more films but what happens
after those two films well sadly we may
end up right back where we started
Marvel and Sony working out another deal
now this could pretty much go on forever
but of course neither company wants that
to happen and today we have some news
that Disney is thinking about buying the
rights to spider-man outright from Sony
this would obviously be the best
scenario for Marvel and Disney as they
would no longer have to worry about the
rights to spider-man because they would
own him they could go on to use
spider-man in the MCU in any films that
they want so could this happen well
let's go ahead and break down this new
report quick reminder to subscribe to my
channel leave a comment down below and
like the video to enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 so
today's news comes from the one and only
Mikey Sutton Mikey has become a very
reliable source for the MCU specifically
in regards to spider-man and actually
yahoo.com has recently done an article
on Mikey stating that he is a trusted
insider source and yesterday he posted a
scoop saying that Disney still wants to
buy the rights to spider-man which of
course they do they don't want to share
him they want to be able to use him in
the MCU they want complete ownership of
him and Mikey says that Disney is
planning to offer around four to five
billion dollars for the rights to
spider-man
now there was previous reports going
around that Sony wanted ten billion for
spider-man but that is an insanely high
number so Disney offering up four to
five billion is right around where it
should be Mikey went on to address the
fact that a company could come in and
buy Sony and if this did happen the
rights to spider-man would go back to
Marvel however he says that companies
cannot simply sit around and wait for
deals to happen especially deals that
are not concrete and especially deals
that could take years to accomplish as
we learned from the Disney Foxx deal one
company buying another does not happen
overnight
it can literally take years and
spider-man is a huge priority for Marvel
right now and Mikey says that with Iron
Man and cow
and America gone the MCU needs another
anchor and the perfect anchor for the
MCU is of course spider-man now Mikey
goes on to say that the New Deal that
Disney and Sony made with each other is
not going to be enough for Disney yes
they got a better deal but they're going
to want all of the rights to spider-man
and of course this makes sense Disney
just spent a ton of money purchasing
back the Marvel characters from Fox the
x-men the Fantastic Four Deadpool
Galactus doom they're all back to Disney
and Marvel they want all of the
characters and now it's time for
spider-man to be home completely and
again according to Mikey Disney is
planning on offering around four to five
billion dollars to Sony to buy Spiderman
outright this will hopefully happen
because if it does Marvel and Disney can
do whatever they want with spider-man
but we'll have to wait and see and until
then we can get really excited for the
next spider-man film coming out less
than a year away and then hopefully get
another team-up film with spider-man in
the MCU not too long after so let me
know what you're looking forward to the
most with the future of spider-man and
the MCU with the movies that we
currently have would you like to see him
team-up with Deadpool would you like to
see him team-up with venom would you
like to see the Green Goblin or the
sinister six let me know what you would
like to see happen in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe to my channel like this video
leave a comment down below so you can
enter my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU don't
forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof